[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen hier bei Tatort
Deutschland wir haben uns heute wieder
einen spannenden Fall rausgesucht und
wir freuen uns natürlich wenn ihr uns
später eine Bewertung hinterlasst oder
wenn ihr es noch nicht getan habt auch
die Glocke aktiviert damit ihr keine
Folge von uns verpasst
in den 70er Jahren muss das Haus in der
Langen Straße Hausnummer 88 89 in
berlin-weichen der Block wird gesprengt
heute steht an dieser Ecke ein
Wohnhochhaus und der Ostbahnhof aber der
berühmteste Bewohner dieser Adresse ist
immer noch präsent als Figur im großen
Kabinett Berlin
mein Name ist Karl Großmann
man nennt mich den bekanntesten
Serienmörder Deutschlands morgen wird
meine Gehilfin Marie Nitsche einen
Wurststand am Ostbahnhof Berlin aufbauen
traust du dich zu kommen in Berlin
Friedrichshain
mein Name ist Marie Mädchen und ich
kenne in dieser Gegend wirklich jeden
den letzten Zug hast du wohl verpasst
was
na dann musst du wohl mit mir Vorlieben
nehmen
wir reden heute also über den
Serienmörder Karl Großmann ich bin Toni
Heyer und mit mir ist wieder der
wunderbare Mirko Casimir hallo Mirko
hallo Toni wir beginnen diese Geschichte
am 13 Dezember 1863 im brandenburgischen
Neuruppin hier wird Karl Großmann
geboren er ist eines von sieben Kindern
in einer Familie von lumpensammlern das
klingt vielleicht wie ein Schimpfwort
ist es damals aber nicht denn es ist ein
richtiger Beruf
Lumpensammler Reisen durch Dörfer und
Städte und bitten in den Straßen und
textilabfälle und Schrott den Stoff
können Sie unter anderem ein Buchdrucker
verkaufen aber so etwas anderes als sein
Vater er wird schlachterlehrling in der
örtlichen Metzgerei der Familie klaut
da ist er gerade 13 Jahre alt aber schon
da ist Karl ja
bisschen anders gestrickt irgendwie er
äußert den Kollegen gegenüber schräge
Gewaltphantasien auch sein Bruder Franz
ist entsetzt von Karls blutrünstigen
Ideen
schließlich gab es da auch noch die
Chefin Frau kliefert an und wird im
dritten Lehrjahr entlassen Großmann geht
ins rund 70 Kilometer entfernte Berlin
wo er erstmal wieder in einer
Fleischerei arbeitet dann rutscht er
langsam ab privat wie auch beruflich
Großmann zieht nach Süddeutschland er
schlägt sich jetzt als Bettler durch
klaut hin und wieder Sachen und verkauft
sie er verbüßt mehrere kürzere
Gefängnisstrafen
zwischendurch dient er sogar ein Jahr
beim Militär wird aber auch da wieder
entlassen außerdem gibt er sich über die
Jahre seinen Sex und Gewaltfantasien hin
oft befriedigt er sich an Tieren wie
Ziegen z.B
1899 eskaliert sein brutaler waren er
vergewaltigt nacheinander ein zehn und
ein vierjähriges Mädchen das Kleinkind
liegt den Verletzungen und Großmann wird
in Bayreuth zu 15 Jahren Gefängnis
verurteilt
nach seiner Entlassung kehrt er 1914
nach Berlin zurück gerade ist der erste
Weltkrieg ausgebrochen Großmann zieht in
eine Wohnküche im Stadtteil
Friedrichshain Adresse lange Straße
88-89 die Bude liegt im vierten Stock
des quergebäudes einigen Quellen zufolge
ist der Untermieter bei der Familie von
Manfred Itzig großmann hält in der
Wohnung auch einen Vogel in einem Käfig
einen Zeisig den er Hense kennt
Berlin von 1910 bis in die 20er Jahre
die Stadt boomt sie ist grell und hat
dunkle Schatten
als Großmann in die Stadt kommt herrscht
schon seit mehr als 25 Jahren Kaiser
Wilhelm II die Politik ist rückständig
aber der technische Fortschritt Rast
innerhalb weniger Jahre sind ganze
Stadtteile samt U-Bahnen und modernen
Fabriken von Siemens AEG oder Osram aus
dem Boden geschossen die Industrie lockt
hunderttausende in die Großstadt
riesige Mietskasernen mit zahlreichen
Hinterhöfen entstehen im Wedding im
Prenzlauer Berg Neukölln und
Friedrichshain
aber mit der Bevölkerung wächst auch das
Elend oft haben die Kinder keine eigenen
Betten wenn der Lohn der Väter nicht
reicht werden Schlafplätze an völlig
fremde vermietet die Zeit ist eine Ära
verarmte Stadtbewohner die schlecht oder
gar nicht sozialversichert sind viele
bekommen Tuberkulose das Leben ist oft
anonym in genau diesem Biotop fühlt sich
Karl Großmann wohl
der grobschlächtige Karl aus Neuruppin
verdient sein Geld jahrelang als
Straßenhändler er verkauft Kämme
Streichhölzer billige kleine Spiegel
Sicherheitsnadeln Druckknöpfe
Haarspangen und Lockenwickler später
betreibt er außerdem einen Wurststand am
Schlesischen Bahnhof so heißt der
Ostbahnhof
bald hat groß Mann so gut verdient dass
er sich noch eine Gartenlaube am
Stadtrand in Altlandsberg zulegt immer
wieder sucht er sich sogenannte
Haushälterinnen
arbeitslose Frauen die sich aus
Verzweiflung prostituieren solche
Haushälterinnen die gehen bei groß man
jahrelang ein und aus auch noch als der
Krieg wieder vorbei ist und er unter
Nachbarn schon als alter Codes geht
die Frauen Putzen nicht nur sie erfüllen
Großmann gegen Geld auch bizarre
sexuelle Wünsche sie heißen wie später
in einem Aufsatz über den Fall
aufgelistet wird Margarete Maria Marta
Johanna Helene oder Anna
denn jeden Tag gibt es am Bahnhof neue
Frauen die aus der Provinz kommen um
Arbeit zu suchen sie stehen da
überwältigt vom Gewusel der großen Stadt
orientierungslos und ängstlich
vielleicht auch hungrig von der langen
Fahrt und dann steht da der onkelhafte
leutselige Karl Großmann und bietet im
charmanten berlinerisch eine Unterkunft
und einen Job an die größte Lust
verspürt er wenn er sie fesselt und
foltert hat die Nachbarn hören immer
wieder Schreie aus der Wohnung im
vierten Stock aber sie nehmen diese
Geräusche nicht ernst im Gegenteil im
Haus wird augenzwinkernd gelästert über
den ollen zu Hause und seine ständig
wechselnden Mädels
Lärm gäbe es in den besten Familien der
Großmann habe ja wohl Qualitäten als
Kavalier auch dass die Haushälterinnen
ständig Wechsel wird einfach hingenommen
genauso gleichgültig verhalten sich auch
die Polizisten im kleinen Revier
Andreasstraße allen voran oberwacht
Meister Clan da kreuzt Großmann mehrfach
auf und behauptet eine Wirtschafterin
habe ihn bestohlen und sich anschließend
aus dem Staub gemacht
fatalerweise stimmt das sogar mindestens
einmal da hat eine Frau namens Anna ihm
Geldscheine gestohlen und wird später
damit erwischt
die Polizei fühlt sich also bestätigt
und lässt Großmann mit seinen ständig
wechselnden haushälteren einfach
gewähren nicht mal als in Berlin ständig
Leichenteile gefunden werden fällt bei
irgendjemandem der Groschen mal entdeckt
jemand einen Frauenkopf mal einen
weiblichen Torso dann wieder ein Bein
oder einen Arm bis zum Frühjahr 1921
tauchen die Körperteile von bis zu 23
Frauen auf die meisten im luisen
städtischen Kanal und in einem Basar
namens Engelbecken bevor wir mit Karl
Großmann weitermachen müssen wir uns mal
kurz ein bisschen in der Zeit
orientieren denn ohne die Umstände von
damals lässt sich diese ganze ich nenne
es jetzt mal Schlamperei der Polizei
nicht erklären und die Gleichgültigkeit
der Leute also unser Fall und die
Leichenfunde die spielen in der Phase
von 1918 bis 1921
Deutschland hat gerade den Ersten
Weltkrieg verloren und muss seit
zufrieden von Versailles
milliardenschwere
Entschädigungszahlungen an die
Kriegsgegner überweisen außerdem hat
eine demokratische Revolution die
Monarchie weggefegt der Kaiser musste
abdanken und lebt jetzt in Holland
Deutschland ist in dieser Frühphase der
Republik fiebrich und aufgewühlt
kaisertreue und extreme Rechte bekämpfen
die Demokratie ebenso wie Kommunisten
die für eine rette Republik kämpfen die
Wirtschaft liegt am Boden die Atmosphäre
ist sehr aggressiv
ja und auch bei der Polizei in Berlin
ist alles neu und ungewohnt in diesen
Jahren sie folgt nicht mehr den Regeln
des Militärs sondern bekommt eine eigene
Struktur im Kaiserreich hatten sich
schlecht ausgebildete Ex-Soldaten um
alles gekümmert also mal um einen Unfall
mal um einen Mord jetzt soll es aber
Spezialisten geben
Schutzpolizisten für Alltagsaufgaben
Kriminalbeamte für Verbrechen sondern
die zernate für Wirtschaftsverbrechen
und so weiter gute Ideen aber in den
Jahren über die wir jetzt sprechen
herrscht für die rund 15.000 Polizisten
in Berlin oft Chaos sie müssen
politische Wechsel an ihrer Spitze
ertragen gewalttätige Demos sogar einen
Putschversuch und auch wenn es
unglaublich klingt die Polizei hat sich
gerade kurz zuvor schon mit einem
Serienmörder rumgeschlagen mit Friedrich
Schumann dem Massenmörder vom
Falkenhagener See der beging zwischen
1918 und 1920 mehrere Vergewaltigungen
11 Mordversuche und sechs Morde sie er
wütete wir 1919 aufflug und schließlich
1921 hingerichtet wurde das erzählen wir
euch in einer weiteren Folge
eins kann ich schon mal Spoilern
Schumann hat den gleichen Anwalt der
auch Großmann vertreten wird fest steht
unser heutiger Bösewicht Karl Großmann
bleibt lange unentdeckt weil die
Umstände für ihn günstig waren aber
Mirko wir kennen das aus anderen Fällen
jetzt wird unser Täter übermütig ne ja
Großmann fühlt sich ganz offensichtlich
sehr sicher aber wahrscheinlich ist
jetzt auch bei seinen Nachbarn der Punkt
erreicht an dem sie einfach nicht mehr
wegschauen können 21 august 1921 ein
Sonntag Karl Großmann sucht mal wieder
eine neue Wirtschaft hat und er hat
Hunger
also geht er erstmal zum Essen an den
Schlesischen Bahnhof es gibt Kassler mit
Kartoffelstampf
danach geht er in die paul-singer-straße
hinunter bis zur koppenstraße und biegt
links ein im Dämmerlicht gabelt er eine
junge Frau auf die offenbar gerade
geweint
hatten los junge Fräulein er wird ein
leicht heulen hier ich helfe ihn war so
oder so ähnlich spricht der Kauz im
Sonntagsanzug der Frau gut zu und die
antwortet nee mir kein Kinder helfen ich
bin gerade aus dem Frauengefängnis
entlassen und nun stehe ich auf der
Straße sie heißt Marie Nitsche und
stammt aus Oberschlesien Großmann weiß
wie er sie auf seine Seite ziehen kann
er lädt die Obdachlose auf den
Rummelplatz in die Köpenicker Straße ein
den ganzen Nachmittag fahren die beiden
Karussell essen und trinken Bier gegen
21 Uhr kommt das Paar schließlich zu
langen Straße 88 89 und trifft dort auf
den Nachbarn Robert iglitzki der auch
gerade nach Hause kommt
den Eindruck dass groß Mann und seine
neue Haushälterin ziemlich betrunken
sind aber was soll's nach und nach gehen
alle Bewohner des Blogs schlafen an
diesem Sommer ab
aber nachts kommt wieder Lärm aus
Großmanns kleiner Bude im vierten Stock
nicht irgendein Lärm es sind Schreie
schreckliche Schreie das Ehepaare
klitzki liegt wach im Bett du musst was
tun sagt iglitzkis Frau ach der olle
wieder es ist doch oft laut erwidert er
diesmal ist es zu schlimm die klitzki
gibt nach zieht sich an und rennt zum
Revier in der Andreasstraße dort trifft
er auf Oberwachtmeister Clan und
überzeugt ihn davon dass etwas Schlimmes
passiert in der Langen Straße als klein
und seine Kollegen bei Großmann klopfen
wickelt der ab kommen sie morgen wieder
hier ist nicht ruft er durch die Tür
aber die Polizisten drücken die Tür auf
sie sehen wie groß man eine Tasse mit
Flüssigkeit zum Mund führen will seine
Hände sind blutig klein schlägt ihm die
Tasse aus der Hand
später wird man feststellen dass der
alte Kauz Großmann sich gerade mit
Zyankali umbringen wollte nach dem
ersten Schrecken sehen die Polizisten
was für eine barbarische Szene sich
ihnen bietet im Bett liegt eine
blutüberströmte verstümmelte Frau als
der geschockte Clan sich zu ihr
herunterbeugt atmet sie noch schwach
dann stirbt sie in seinem Küchenofen
finden die Ermittler verkohlte Überreste
menschliche Hände als der
blutverschmierte Karl Großmann abgeführt
wird hat sich vor dem Haus eine
Menschenmenge versammelt die die
jahrelang nichts unternommen haben rufen
jetzt Mörder und hinrichten muss man
denen vieles was wir ab jetzt über die
Verhöre und schließlich über den Prozess
gegen Karl Großmann Wissen stammt von
seinem Anwalt Professor Dr Erich frei er
ist eine Berühmtheit seiner Zeit wie
Toni vorhin schon erwähnte vertrat der
Advokat schon den Serienmörder Schumann
Überfälle wie groß man und Schumann
schrieb später ein Buch im Verhör mit
Kriminalkommissar Werneburg Großmann
widerwillig zu dass er marinete tödlich
verletzt hat angeblich zur Strafe weil
die ihn bestehen wollte aber mit den
zahlreichen Leichenfunden im Kanal da
will er nichts zu tun haben mit den
vielen vermissten Jungfrauen auch nicht
aber Werneburg ist hartnäckig und
trickreich er verhört Großmann weiter
Stunden und Tage lang und der Gewinn
schließlich das Vertrauen des
Massenmörders weil er seinen Vogel in
die U-Haft bringen lässt sei sich
hensekin und nach und nach gesteht Karl
Großmann jetzt erst den Mord an Marie
Nitsche und dann weitere Morde in seiner
Wohnung höchstens fünf seines gewesen
beteuert er am ersten juli 1922 beginnt
vor der ersten Kammer am Berliner
Landgericht der Mordprozess gegen Karl
Großmann
angeklagt ist er wegen drei Frauen
Morden die ihm die Staatsanwaltschaft
nachweisen kann sein Verteidiger ist der
schon erwähnte Staranwalt Erich frei
allerdings hält sich der Presse Rummel
zum Prozess Auftakt in Grenzen denn
erstens streiken die Zeitungsdruckereien
in diesen Sommertagen und zweitens
beherrscht gerade ein spektakulärer
politischer Mord alle Gespräche in
Berlin am Morgen des 24 Juni 1922 wurde
Außenminister Walter rathenauer in
Berlin Grunewald auf der Fahrt ins
Auswärtige Amt von Angehörigen der
rechtsextremen Organisation Konsul
erschossen und noch bevor die
Hauptverhandlung enden kann er hängt
sich Karl Großmann am 5 juli mit
Bettlaken in seiner Zelle er nimmt das
wahre Ausmaß seiner Morde mit ins Grab
Kriminal historiker schätzen dass er 20
bis 100 Menschen umgebracht hat auf
jeden Fall kommt der Massenmörder zu
zweifelhaft im Ruhm genau wie wenig
später Fritz Hamann wird er zur blutigen
gruselfigur deren Geschichte man immer
weiter ausschmückt so heißt es von
Großmann bald er habe an seinem
Wurststand am Schlesischen Bahnhof
Menschenfleisch in Dosen verkauft
spektakulär ist auch das Gericht das
unter seinen Opfern eine Zarentochter
gewesen sein die soll nach Großmanns
Attacke auf sie im Irrenhaus gelandet
sein nichts davon lässt sich nachweisen
und ganz ehrlich
das ganze tut auch nichts zur Sache die
Geschichte von Karl Großmann die ist so
schon traurig und furchtbar genug und
damit sind wir am Ende unseres heutigen
falls angelangt wir haben ihn
recherchiert mit Auszügen aus dem Buch
von Erich Frey mit dem Titel ich
beantrage Freispruch sowie zwei
spannenden Aufsätzen die das Geschehen
teils literarisch verarbeiteten auch im
Archiv von Axel Springer fanden sich
Zusammenfassung Skript Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion durch die wake-studios
München wir freuen uns wenn ihr auch
beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei seid
euer Mirko und eure Toni